[Música]
há oito anos como desenhistas
industriais que somos
a gente tem desenhado produtos das mais
diferentes áreas e neles gente tenta
materializar um pouquinho de significado
na vida das pessoas
são projetos que das mais diferentes
áreas para empresas dos mais diferentes
segmentos materiais malucos alguns
produtos nem sabe o que é um direito na
verdade
e a gente tem uma atuação internacional
levando também o nome do brasil lá fora
e muita gente pergunta como é que a
gente consegue fazer projetos tão
diferentes mas mesmo assim tem uma
identidade e bom o segredo pra vocês é
que a gente é orgulhosamente
especialista e não ser especialista em
absolutamente nada
então a gente gostaria de compartilhar
uma jornada com vocês pra gente fazer
junto a gente realmente acredita que
cada um tem um reino se você tem um rei
no terreno
todo mundo tem o próprio rio esse reino
é o teu conhecimento e com o tempo e com
muito trabalho duro você recebe pedras
joguinhos para você acabar construindo
alguma coisa dentro do teu reino box
para conseguir o que quiser você tem
essa liberdade
a gente sabe que você pode construir
muros
você pode usar construir castelos
palácios chatô sul
você pode construir o que você quiser
cabe a você
só que a gente acredita que você
construindo sol musicais tellus você
acaba só protegendo cada vez mais o teu
próprio conhecimento eles certa forma
isolando ele do mundo com esses mesmos
jogos com essas mesmas pedras
a gente acha que é possível você
construir então com essas duas
experiências com os seus aprendizados
você pode construir bons e aí a coisa
fica legal
com essas pontes você consegue ter
acesso aos mais diferentes reinos e essa
é uma maneira de você conseguir expandir
o teu próprio reino e acabar afetando
com outras diferentes áreas e só
enriquecendo cada vez mais o seu próprio
conhecimento bom
oito anos atrás no início da nossa
jornada a gente tava super confortáveis
no nosso reino onde criava coisas como
dinho e junho foi nosso primeiro projeto
a ser convidado para ser exposta na
semana de design de milão e é uma coisa
muito simples é simplesmente a
materialização de uma crença materno e
paterno os filho a filha por mais
agitada por mais explícita que possa ser
correndo pra lá e pra cá toda hora que
ela está ali sentadinho e desenhando
fazendo que foi o pai a mãe ou olha e
fala a cbg
ali a gente começou a perceber a
importância de materializar poesia não
só a importância de trazer poesia do dia
a dia das pessoas quanto isso pode tocar
o coração delas
então ali ele também percebeu que a
gente estava na nossa zona de conforto
da zona de conforto é um lugar muito
sedutor é simples aproveitar muito mais
fácil também ficar lá só que por outro
lado também é um entrave soeiro é
gostoso é confortável ficar na zona de
conforto obviamente só que a gente
sempre percebeu o quanto isso pode ser
perigoso porque quando você fica
limitado sozinho confortável no seu
reino e acaba limitando também tudo
aquilo que você pode entregar pra
humanidade
tudo aquilo que você pode fazer além do
seu potencial é justamente no seu
potencial
então a gente sempre foi obcecado por
estrapolar sua zona de conforto
extrapolar e querer conhecer novas
realidades queria conhecer novas
possibilidades e ali
bom a gente assim a gente continua
gostando muito de desenhar móveis gosta
bastante disso ainda nós a gente quis
conhecer novas áreas
a gente quis construir o nosso reino
pontes a maior quantidade de reinos que
a gente poderia ter poderia conhecer e
aí a gente começou essa nossa jornada
a gente começou a caminhar e do nosso
reino onde a gente fazia muito disso a
gente começou a conhecer o maior número
de armas possível
ele percebeu que era nesse mundo que a
gente vive em tantos lugares
maravilhosos tanto os reinos
então vale tão variados cada um com a
sua beleza cada um com a sua
profundidade e bom além de móveis
malucos
a gente vai mostrar um projeto que a
gente fez pontes com dois reinos
maravilhosos para só se atinge uma
profundidade ainda maior nesse projeto
foi chamado de uma empresa empresa
global para a gente desenvolver um
produto para crianças porque a gente
descobriu que a principal causa de morte
acidental entre crianças na américa
latina são acidentes de trânsito ea
gente sabe que grande maioria dessas
mortes poderiam ter sido evitadas se a
criança tivesse usando o cinto de
segurança
porém a gente sabe que não tem incentivo
pra criança usar o cinto e também com
ela está usando tem aquele botão
vermelho sedutora ali que ela vai lá e
ela tá louca petacchi
então a gente quis desenvolver um
acessório de cinto de segurança que
servisse as crianças da melhor maneira
possível
só que a gente não consegue servir elas
não entendeu quando a suspensão como
melhor a gente consegue ser v
por isso gente cria uma ponte correndo
na psicologia e dessa maneira de
conseguir se aprofundar nesse projeto
ele tem uma coisa muito legal a gente
fez baseada nos 4 animaizinhos favoritos
da das crianças na américa latina
e esses animais representam a família
daí a gente também fez uma outra ponte
como escritório fantástico de design
gráfico para ajudar a gente a
ilustrações para ilustrar justamente os
pais do filhote que ficam separados
quando o acessório não está conectado
quando sinto não tá é fechado ea gente
representou os pais de maneira
totalmente simétrica que representasse
igualdade você
então ele pode cabeça ele eles ficam
iguais o casal mas vem site desse reino
da psicologia fantástico que cresceu
muito o projeto de uma maneira da gente
conectar as crianças maior bem como a
eficácia desse projeto inteiro é se as
crianças se identificassem com o projeto
e elas vissem a família delas e não
simplesmente animaizinhos
então ele junto ele vem com uma cartela
de adesivos que a criança pode
customizar isso é uma coisa muito legal
porque a gente receber o feedback das
crianças é videozinhos assim a a criança
mora que ligava a mãe tenha um violão do
pai tem aqui uma gravata por babá e tem
uma boa mãe
só que como a gente sabe que a natureza
ela abraça a diversidade de uma maneira
maravilhosa a gente também quis abraçar
a diversidade na sociedade
então nessa cartela agente
propositalmente colocou mais dessas
insígnias de maneira que se a criança
tem dois pais ela representa os dois
países
se ela tem um pai uma mãe beleza ela tem
uma mãe e uma avó que cuida dela
fantástico ela tem um casal de mães
incrível então a criança não sente só
segurança no trânsito não fica só segura
no trânsito mas ela também se sente
insegura com a família que ela tem do
jeitinho que ela é assim a gente
consegue ampliar chegar a um nível de
profundidade muito maior quando nossos
escritórios de tem sido reconhecido cada
vez mais por fazer criações bem
competitivas mas bem na verdade a gente
acredita que a gente simplesmente
construtores de pontes que adora
explorar novas terras e fazer novos
amigos a gente vê que isso é uma maneira
da gente trazer o melhor do futuro
presente maneira da gente fazer isso com
muita eficiência eficácia e bom quando a
gente começa a conectar esses diferentes
risos
o resultado acaba sendo muito maior que
a soma das partes nem percebe que quanto
mais variados os reinos que a gente
conecta mais chances a gente tem de
fazer conexões que talvez não fizesse
sozinho acaba tendo idéias malucas que
talvez não teria se a gente ficasse
dentro da nossa bolha
e assim também teria sido impossível a
gente criar a primeira capa de prótese
de perna produzido em massa no mundo
se a gente não tivesse justamente criar
dessas pontes os reinos ali de área
médica reino de protegidas
fisioterapeutas e até dos próprios
deputados as pessoas queriam usar esse
produto confiável é basicamente uma capa
de proteção que desenvolve a autoestima
das pessoas ea gente tem muito orgulho
de dizer que já está presente em mais de
20 países
a opção mais acessível em todos esses
países a gente consegue ver milhares e
milhares de pessoas inclusive nas redes
sociais postando foto de corpo inteiro
que é linda de ver expressando sua
própria identidade expressando orgulho
que ela tem de ter o corpo que tem
então assim a gente poderia sim olhar
além do nosso reino flertar com as
outras áreas usando um binóculo ele
poderia pegar um binóculo e dar uma
olhada ali na área médica dá uma olhada
ali nos outros anos a gente poderia
fazer isso lendo poderia fazer isso uma
certa distância mas só quando a gente
realmente construir uma ponte chega lá e
vivencia aquela realidade como aquela
pessoa
aí sim a gente consegue muito mais a
fundo e consegue e muito além do que
acaba sendo muito mais assertivo bom
direta ou indiretamente independente da
área tudo que a gente faz a gente faz
para as pessoas
a gente percebe a importância que tem de
observar de ter empatia que tem
compaixão que assim conseguem entender
melhor o que passa na cabeça e no
coração das pessoas que conseguem criar
melhor o que for pra qualquer pessoa que
seja esse tudo que a gente fizer poderá
contribuir para uma unidade de alguma
forma melhor a gente realmente acredita
que a parte mais bonita então a inovação
a parte mais bonita do design ela é
justamente nessa conexão tem a gente une
diferentes universos une diferentes
reinos só dessa maneira a gente consegue
atingir profundidades muito maiores e
consegui servir a sociedade de uma
maneira muito mais profunda e eficaz
também
a gente realmente acredita que juntos a
gente consegue criar é juntar só juntos
a gente consegue criar pontes para criar
uma unidade é um futuro cada vez mais
humano e cada vez mais inovador e cada
vez mais repleto de significados
fica aqui o convite para a gente criar
pontes juntos
obrigado
[Aplausos]